I don't know but I do know is Raymond
Cruz is probably gonna beat the [ __ ] out
of some oh yeah he's gonna be the [ __ ]
out of all your own that's all I wanted
he's in this movie as too good yeah it
takes place in New Mexico they're like
[Laughter]
how did you reject nation I'm Greg Alba
and I'm John old 7:00 a.m. right now for
us we are going to watch the trailer for
the curse la la la la la la ah damn it
I've been trying to roll their own ah la
llorona llorona llorona with a new
non-latin people tried sing the Spanish
words before we go into that I wanted to
say thank you to everyone who has been
following us over at patreon yo over
there we do weekly Q&A s as well as TV
show reactions for many of shows that
includes attack on Titan my hero
academia Full Metal Alchemist
Brotherhood we also covered Gotham
Riverdale and supernatural which I'm
sure this will have it's supernatural
elements let's get into it shall we
Warner Brothers continuing therefore
things gonna go to their horror movie
studio tour thingy horrors may get here
you know anything about my aroma the
weeping woman pretty sure I've seen him
play a priest yes Linda Cardellini
Carnival Cruise this feels like a
contrary
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
hide your kids hide your wife oh yes oh
why they have to have that kind of car
[Music]
oh man
interesting I like these horror movies
because every time we do one they're
like what's another thing that we
haven't made a jump-scare yet let's get
one of those crank windows yeah I'm
pretty sure he's already made the
conjuring three or I was supposed to be
in one of the contract movies and now
she is here yeah her own spin-off movies
before that movie comes up now I know
this is this guy's own project this does
have James wants producer touch all over
this bad boy I mean this definitely
feels like it's of that tunnel style you
know it feels like BB has their horror
movie aesthetic yeah and and now more
than ever it's defined yeah and this
take place in Mexico looked like it
right
I believe the actual story is supposed
to take place in New Mexico and like
SantaFe if I'm not mistaken but I
couldn't exactly tell with this I mean
yeah the kids sounded American yeah yeah
we went to Mexico most people there
seemed bilingual oh yeah everyone was
like you're out of there yeah that's
crazy bad like don't worry you can ever
really accurate documentary lakes or
rivers I appreciate the way this trailer
is constructed because WB has a way of
constructing their trailers to where
they let the moments really play out you
mean of course they're still cut up in
their own way but yeah they're cut up in
a way where you feel like you're
watching the scene play out yeah you got
like a few glimpses at the plot and then
you do a prolonged set piece of some
kind yeah showcase with the scariness
yeah it's one thing for James Wan to
like be a producer on this on the
spin-off movies and then hire director
there yeah whatever
for him to take over the conjuring three
that seems to be a lot of the big talk
about this movies big shoes man he's
like well James Wan did a great job with
conjuring one and two he produced this
one and clearly loves what he did here
and he's like alright well I don't want
to do contra III you do you do contra
III because you seem like the perfect
person to continue it knowing that peace
information is weirdly more than the
trailer the number one thing selling me
on this movie it's like a huge vote of
confidence right out the gate and like
that no matter what is hype for this
movie because now it's all of us coming
and going what does Michael Chavez have
you know like what is his eye what is
his neck I mean that jump-scare the
first one were the good kids seeing oh
yeah they're the fence isn't it
channeling that she comes over from the
other side yeah it's a similar
jump-scare to the one in the nun which
is like your eyes looking here but it
comes from this side instead not
expecting to come from a different angle
a similar type of jump-scare but it's
still a really good one yeah I mean it
looked I thought the part where she
disappears into the blackness especially
sold that because you know you're just
like she could just be standing very
still yeah you know in the weirdness of
those shadows and stuff and then yeah
coming out of the foreground I feel like
that's one of the bigger elements that
they're gonna have to like keep fresh
and stuff because especially in the past
couple years is ghost stories and
haunting stories and these kinds of
things have become like so popular it's
like watching insidious for one of the
things I noticed was like we're really
bending over backwards to misdirect my
eyes and yeah jump scares please well
this still seems like it has all the
things that would make one of these kind
of horror movies work like the mother
character is seems fine but the kids
seem like the son seems like a real kid
yeah now his fear and then a few lines
we get from him seems like a really good
performance and it's a little boy this
time and that crazy little girl little
girl bring it back just for a hot second
if this takes place in Mexico I'm really
confused why no one's speaking Spanish
at all in this trailer yeah maybe
because it's just the trailer the
English speaking both the US baby it's
maybe it's American family moves to
Mexico and I get there's a lot of you
know bilingual people out there
especially the woman who says I don't
know yeah which is the most satisfying
like I do love like cultural folklore
because you know yeah accents and other
languages just add so much
the horror sequences seem directed well
it seems like on paper that they got the
the great kind of characters down
because when they have good characters
that feel like family and it seems like
they're going with the same kind of
element here omit though omit there's
part of me it's a little bit worries is
gonna be like unintentionally silly
especially these kind of horror movies
when you take urban legends like this
and then you know you got like the first
part alone I and then like characters
it's just an urban legend and then
someone's like huh not everyone believed
it yeah and then you don't even really
get to explore who she is I mean that's
that's the excitement and the worry for
me about movies like this is like I
really love horror stories that are
based on folklore and I love you know
seeing the depictions of that because
I'm sure that there's gonna be at least
an opportunity for them to show the
folktale itself is just a small kind of
anecdote you know I always like those
depictions but at the same time I'm like
this story is kind of timeless people
have known it for years like it's
existed within cultures so are they
going to be able to realize it in a way
that is as good as what you've been
imagining for so much time that lives up
to yeah that immortal status of this you
know cultural figure or is it gonna be
just another generic horror movie that
borrowed this piece of imagery there are
a lot of creatures like this there are a
lot of ghost stories like this out there
a lot of movies yeah I think in the
finale we're gonna go by the lake Oh
probably will probably be a final oil of
some kind and then some houses you're
gonna come to piece for their kids yeah
if it's anything like what everyone says
at the air relation is yeah yeah you're
gonna take better carrier your kids or
make sure that your kids don't wander by
the river and fall and that's the other
thing too is you got to wonder like is
this just a cautionary tale to get kids
not to go by the river I don't know what
I do know is Raymond cruise is probably
gonna beat the [ __ ] out of some oh yeah
he's gonna be the [ __ ] out while your
own that's all I wanted he's in this
movie as too good yeah
it takes place in New Mexico they're
like
giant guns yeah that would make sense
though cuz I like I said I think this is
supposed to be New Mexico and and that
totally works because that's where to go
live slaughter an urban legend man
alright guys well you can subscribe to
the reject nation click that
notification bell check us on patreon TV
show reactions q and A's and love to
have you become a patron yet today